these Spanish travelers at Madrid
Airport are some of the last Europeans
to be allowed into the US if the US have
to take those measures let them take
them we need to be prudent and careful
but there's no need to get desperate it
affects me because I work in the u.s. I
had to change my ticket and bring the
trip forward because if not I would have
found the border closed the new u.s.
rules mark a sudden escalation and
Trump's response to the virus and they
seem to catch us allies and the markets
off guard as well as making political
waves they will be a huge blow to
travelers and to airlines operating
routes across the Atlantic the tourism
industry has already been hit hard by
the virus as governments tighten
restrictions and travelers think twice
about whether to go on vacation in these
uncertain times
well Trump's travel ban caught a lot of
people by surprise here in Europe let's
go over to correspondent Barron to
Riegert who's standing by for us in
Brussels hi Behrendt EU leaders have
been holding an emergency meeting to
discuss this decision from the White
House what's emerged from that meeting
the you Commission and also the 27
member states issued a statement saying
that they disapprove of this travel ban
especially because there was no
consultation no warning that this would
come in the you says that doesn't make
sense because this is a global virus and
you cannot contain it by just forbid
people to travel and asked to comment on
the allegations the President Trump made
in his speech the spokesperson of the
Commission only said we have more
serious things to do than to deal with
that and what does this u.s. travel ban
mean for Europeans that means that
travelers from 26 so-called Schengen
countries cannot travel to the US these
are not all EU member states for example
Romania Bulgaria
Island and not part of the Schengen zone
so these citizens can travel but also
Switzerland in Norway I included in this
pan and Great Britain is also not
included and but the Commission says
it's not quite clear how this will work
in practice because they have no
information how this travel ban will be
implemented does it concern only
European carriers or does it concern
American carriers also and you know
there are many mixed carriers like
United and Lufthansa okay LM in the Air
France and the Commission does not know
how this will actually worked for
starting on Saturday morning regardless
it could be very difficult for the
European economy banned so what is the
EU doing to address that yeah there will
certainly be an impact on the economy or
can you can already see that this
morning or the stock exchanges in Europe
down the shareholders expect things to
get worse obviously and the European
Central Bank is meeting today to come up
with some countermeasures but there are
limitations because the interest rates
in Europe are already at zero point zero
so the ECB might decide to buy more
government bonds or more company bonds
but this is all very limited and the
Commission also established a fund to to
ease the impact of Karuna rise and verse
25 billion euros yesterday Baron do you
know there is frustration even anger
over this travel ban but the w-h-o is
calling for drastic measures so it's a
time for the European Union to consider
similar travel restrictions the European
Union's the whole is not convinced that
travel bans are the right thing to do
right now because the virus is already
everywhere so what sense does a travel
ban make right now but on the other hand
you have to say that the u.s. is not the
only
Continent doing that also Israel India
and just recently Guatemala are banning
people from Europe to travel to their
territory and also within Europe their
travel bans in place for example Austria
and Hungary stopped all travelers from
Italy to their countries though this is
a very mixed picture here
all right UW's band record reporting
there from Brussels Thank You DW is Nina
Haase is following the latest
developments on this story for us hi
Nina this is a pretty big step from the
White House how is Europe reacting oh it
is a huge step and the EU's top
officials have already slammed this
decision and they've said essentially
that the coronavirus is a global crisis
it's not limited to any continent it
requires cooperation rather than
unilateral action this is what the EU
Commission president was a laFonda lion
and the EU Council President Jean Michel
said in a joint statement as a reaction
to that decision and they were extremely
unhappy about the fact that they were
not consulted or they weren't not even
informed about this decision taken by
the US president and then Radek Sikorski
who's a member of the european
parliament and former polish foreign
minister said on twitter that I'm
surprised that a possible British
coronaviruses deem preferable to an EU
one playing politics he said with health
is a bad idea and that of course refers
to that exemption for Britain by Donald
Trump okay so we see that this is not
really going down that well here in
Europe at least they felt they should
have been consulted at the same time the
whu-oh is recommending drastic measures
I mean is it time then that Europe
followed the US and also issue similar
travel restrictions a travel ban well
you always have to look at the political
systems in the countries both the
European Union and Germany for example
if you want to talk about the reaction
of one of the member states of the
European Union they are federal systems
so decisions when it comes to health
policy when it comes to education policy
etc they're always taken at national
level on the EU level and at regional
level here in Germany and so it's up to
local authorities regional authorities
here in Germany for example to implement
and bans on mass gatherings of more than
a thousand people and also the EU they
have to coordinate their efforts by the
various Member States they're all
speaking with different voices and it
just takes a lot of time to bring all
these different actors together and
decide on a more coordinated strategy
when it comes to combating the virus
well here in Germany yesterday we heard
the Chancellor Angela Merkel say that
according to health officials she's
spoken to 60 to 70 percent of the German
population will be infected with this
virus how are people reacting to that
well that's not a number that she makes
up I mean Angela Merkel clearly is
somebody who listens to experts this is
a number that's been passed on by
leading virologists in this country who
give daily updates on statistics and
they look at how the virus is probably
going to develop in the course of the
next few weeks and months and what is
clear is that the virus is here to stay
it has reached Germany and all we have
to do is make sure that we gain enough
time that not everybody gets sick at the
same time to not strain our healthcare
system too much and this is something
that Angela Merkel has understood and so
she wants the public to understand that
everybody can do their share to help
slow down that infection rate at the
same time we saw the Czech Prime
Minister we should say at the Czech
Republic shares a border with Germany
accusing the German Chancellor of
spreading panic with those numbers what
did you make of that well again this is
something where we clearly see that
Europe is not talking with one voice
that not every country in the European
Union is as affected as for example
Italy the numbers are different
approaches are different the health care
systems are different but what the EU
leaders decided earlier this week was
that health ministers were going to talk
to each other on a daily basis to tackle
the coronavirus together and this is
something at least that's putting the EU
on a good path GWS Nina Hauser with us
here in studio thank you very much and
we can speak now to dr. Jacomo gas le
he's an anesthesiologist from the
University of Milan he's coordinating
the network of intensive care units in
Lombardy dr. casselli we know you're
busy at the moment thank you for joining
us here on DW can you give us an idea of
what the situation is in hospitals right
but right now in Lombardy yes to give
you an idea I can give you just some
very simple numbers like before this
crisis we had in Lombardy around maximum
800 ICU beds available for people and
since the start of the epidemics so in
the last 20 days we have admitted to our
ICU a total of more than 900 people of
these let's say 120 have been discharged
about 90 have died and the remaining
around 700 are still there so you from
these numbers you can you can understand
how how big is the stress of the system
so we've been able to increase our ICU
beds capacity by about 50% something
like that which a huge effort everyone
we have reorganized our hospital network
in order to centralize the
time-dependent diseases like for example
traumas stroke in only in few hubs and
to free space to have new units
dedicated we have created a network of
specialized coffee 19 units in several
hospitals and so until now we've been
able to cope with this incredible amount
of patients in a very short limited
period of time but you know Lombardi is
very rich and in modern Region sorry one
of the region richest region in Europe
and still really struggling to to deal
with this incredible as I say tsunami of
patients who is investing us yeah we've
heard reports of nurses of doctors
working around the clock working past
capacity to be able to treat enough
people we've also heard reports of
nurses health care officials having to
reach almost impossible decisions of
deciding because there are so many sick
people at the moment to treat who to
treat and who they cannot is that true
and and who is reaching that choice well
that's a very important that's a very
important point and there are a lot of
poly mix now in Italy but but
I have I want to make this very clear
well in everydays life and
anesthesiologist one is called to see a
critical patient has to take take a
decision whether I see one admission is
proportionate for that patient condition
I mean that we admit to the ICU all the
patient who can benefit from ICU
admission and intensive treatments and
if the patient cannot benefit because of
a number of factors which is not only
age of course but it's age past
illnesses morbid chronic conditions and
and in quality of life and so on if the
patient does not benefit from ICU
admission he will not be admitted to the
ICU no matter how many free beds you
have yeah we understand it's a really
difficult situation that you're facing
right now a lot of people are looking to
Italy and staying with more than ten
thousand cases what has happened there I
mean why has the virus spread so quickly
there it's very difficult to say
apparently here in Lombard it happens
something similar to what happened in in
Wuhan probably the virus was was was
around for at least has been around for
at least one month are recognized and
then something happened like a super
spread event that like started this fire
which is very difficult to turn off and
clearly we're having a huge number of
patients an increasing number of
patients and what's different from at
least what was reported from China is
that the number of patients in the ICU
because in our in our case serious at
least 10 to 12 percent of the patient of
the positive patient need ICU admission
compared to let's say less than 5
percent in the in the Chinese population
so what I want to make very clear and
what what to say to tell everyone in the
world is that the solution for this is
not
opening new bells new ICU beds or or
keep buying ventilators this is a
solution for people who are already sick
so the only way to avoid that this
becomes a disaster
and when I say disaster I mean hundreds
of thousands of deaths the only way to
avoid this is to avoid the spread of
this disease and this can be done with
simple behavioral measures yeah so you
can increase your SEO but as as much as
you can but again if you are invested by
this tsunami you're a hero but at a
certain point will never be enough no
matter how efficient modern just just a
cutting quickly there what you're saying
there is your message to other countries
that are facing what your region is
facing right now is please slow the
spread first get ready so prepare your
health care workers with to the proper
use of personal protective equipment for
example reorganize or try to think how
to organize your ICU network but most
importantly prepare the population tell
them that once you have the initial
spread they need to change the behavior
they need to reduce their social life I
mean in theory if everyone stays at home
for three weeks this is going to hand
because no one should be no new patients
should be infected okay so I understand
it's a big limitation about personal
freedom but the other one this is going
to be a disaster all right we'll have to
leave it there doctor Giacomo grass le
and anesthesiologist joining us from the
University of Milan in Lombardy thank
you very much all right let's take a
look at more of the latest coronavirus
developments now a Spain is considering
a lockdown of its capital Madrid Saudi
Arabia has suspended travel by its
citizens and residents and halted
flights to and from several states
Chancellor Angela Merkel's CDU party has
postponed the special conference it was
planning to elect a new leader many
schools across Europe have been closed